thanksgiving is upon us which means that
it's time for normal people to give
thanks to god for the blessings in their
life and it's time for leftists to whine
about how much they hate america
the real story of thanksgiving and some
history you probably never read in your
school books the mythology of
thanksgiving closely mirrors the
mythology of america that mythology is
the image that white americans love to
see of themselves white settlers come to
a strange land in good faith bringing
something of great value that enriches
the people who are already here the
natives also bring something of immense
value equal exchange
that closely mimics the mythology of
white america it is how america wants to
see itself
the truth of course of thanksgiving is
much different the truth is pilgrims did
not bring turkey sweet potato pie or
cranberries to thanksgiving they could
not they were broke they were broken
their hands were out they were begging
they brought nothing of value
but they got fed
they got schooled thanksgiving it makes
sense there is much for white americans
to be thankful for
but i'm still trying to figure out what
indigenous people received of value
so that history is completely wrong the
whole thing is completely wrong all the
way down to the turkeys which the
pilgrims almost certainly did bring to
thanksgiving but this guy's premise is
wrong too
actually the the msnbc host's premise is
wrong too if you're under the age of 40
you almost certainly were taught that
anti-american anti-historical nonsense
in schools in fact that was probably the
only story about thanksgiving you were
taught and it also happens to be total
bunk i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from alex shinprod who
says
those poor individuals in the street
that looted the louis vuitton store were
just trying to put caviar creme brulee
and herb encrusted filet mignon on their
table to feed their families that's so
true they are poor put upon people who
are stealing prada handbags and louis
vuitton and jewelry they're very they're
oppressed and they really they deserve
the foie gras that they are that are
they are simply coveting to feed their
families you know when you want really
nice goods to make your family happy i
would strongly recommend you check out
movement the christmas shopping season
is upon us and movement the original
watch brand to break all the rules has
you covered they are bringing you the
sleekest highest quality gifts of the
season with hundreds of watches blue
light glasses and fine jewelry styles to
choose from
movement is making it easy they've got
beautiful curated gift boxes
they have a his and hers gift guide
they've got free and quick shipping
right to your door just in time
for christmas i've had a number of
movement watches over the years and i
love them all my favorite one i've got
to say is the revolver watch i love it
it's cool black face black dial uh dark
brown strap it's rose rose gold uh
case i don't know how to describe it
it's just super duper cool they have
automatic watches which i love too
they've got i gave one to my father
for christmas he loves it he was a total
smash hit they're just great and and
because they're not particularly
expensive they're you know a great deal
you can buy multiple and wear them on
different days be the big winner this
holiday season with a gift from movement
mvmt.com knowles that's mvmt.com knowles
join the movement that history is just
bs so
what
the guy in the kuji sweater says is that
the story we're told is that the native
americans and the englishmen brought
something to the table at the first
thanksgiving and it more broadly in
their in their cohabitation and they
both benefited from it and that's
totally untrue the englishmen brought
nothing they didn't even bring turkeys
so yes they did you can read in governor
bradford's on plymouth plantation you
can read that even specifically on the
turkey point he sent his men a foulin
they went out they got some birds they
brought some stuff they all came
together and they ate a meal together
and that meal was representative of a
piece
and and an alliance that they formed the
englishman and the native americans
specifically one native american
masasoit the guy says that the indians
did not benefit at all they didn't get
anything from the englishman that's not
true massasoit
who is an indian chieftain
was able to use the englishman to
greatly expand his power in new england
and really helped to create and
certainly to expand the wampanoag nation
he could not have done that without the
englishman in 1623 massasoit the leader
of the indian there the indian tribe
there
was on his deathbed he was dying the
englishman edward winslow out of
friendship went to go visit massasoit
mas as so it said this is all well
recorded massachusetts said edward
winslow i'll never see your face again
edward winslow made him some broth and
gave him some rudimentary medicine and
sat up with him and took care of
massasoit and maza so it recovered and
then massasoit told the edward winslow
and the englishman about a plot from the
other massachusetts indians that were
going to massachusetts or the
narragansett i forget who were
who were making an attack he was in
massachusetts we're making an attempt on
the englishman's lives and they formed
various alliances and they lived
together in in peace for a long time
actually the only reason that the peace
broke down was because massachusetts son
king philip who took an english name who
took a christian name
king philip misinterpreted the death of
his brother and thought the englishman
killed his brother even though they
didn't and so he declared war on them
and some indians sided with the
englishman and some indians sided with
king philip and the peace between the
natives and the englishmen was
irrevocably destroyed
that's the real history the kuji sweater
guy and the
airheaded msnbc lady don't know anything
about that because they don't know much
about anything at all certainly not
about history all they know about is
their ideology which which tells them
that the indians got nothing of value
what else did they get a value um
christianity that would be one thing
that they got a value i i assume that
the msnbc lady and the kuji sweater guy
don't have a great deal of respect for
christianity but they should because the
religion that the natives were
practicing it was a false religion and
it led to some very kooky practices as
as we have noted on this show before
cannibalism was fairly widespread among
certain indian tribes including around
the northeast of the united what is now
the united states there were lots of
terrible religious practices there was
enslavement all sorts of bad things and
the when the englishman came and brought
christianity to the native americans
they
brought true religion they brought some
enlightenment to them and they worked
i'm not saying the indians didn't give
the englishman something of value as
well the englishman would have starved
without the indians in fact one of the
first acts that the englishman committed
when they got to the new world was to
find a bunch of corn that the indians
had stored and they took some of the
corn and they wanted to pay it back
later but they were starving and they
took some so i it just seems to me that
the true history is much more
interesting than the nonsense ideology
that you are in fact taught in schools
it's it's now become a canard it's a
myth to say here's the real
dirty history of america that you
weren't taught no that's all you're
taught now even when i was in school
which was now what i started school in
1995 and graduated high school in 2008
and
still even all the way back then we were
taught almost exclusively certainly by
high school
a negative history
of
the settlers in america
and we were taught history from the
perspective of leftist polemicists who
think that colonization and settling
america was a very terrible thing
really the history that you are not
taught is the history that i just told
you i just gave you a little tiny touch
of it and what i'm not even an academic
historian i just happen to have read a
handful of books on this and so i know
significantly more
than any of these ideological lunatics
on cable news or the fellow wearing the
kuji sweater
the real history is is always much more
interesting than the fables that the
ideologues are trying to tell you
speaking of not being taught things in
school
the energy secretary for joe biden
was just giving a press conference
because gas prices are through the roof
at seven bucks a gallon in california
and she was asked a very simple question
might be
the most elementary question
pertaining to her job she was asked how
many barrels of oil a day does the
united states consume
she didn't know the answer
there's various figures about this i'm
curious if you know how many barrels of
oil does the u.s consume per day i don't
have that number in front of me so some
suggest it's about 18 million which
would suggest you're releasing less than
three days worth of supply from the
petroleum reserve
some have said it's about 18 million
it's actually probably higher than that
it's probably a little over 20 million
20.5 million barrels of oil per day but
whether it's 18 whether it's 20.
don't you think that is a number that
the energy secretary should know i'm not
saying that the energy secretary needs
to have every statistic off the top of
her head
but but that one's pretty basic
when you're applying for the job of
energy secretary that should probably be
the number one question on the quiz
right how much oil does the united
states consume
and she didn't know
yes ideology plays a role in bad
administrations
yes
partisan alliances play a role
there's also just a level of basic
competence that is necessary to have a
good administration
and this administration
doesn't have that
and frankly i think it starts in school
for these people
i think that this energy secretary and
this weak administration
is the logical result of decades of
poor education
of as they say teaching students how to
think not what to think i know a lot of
conservatives recite this very stupid
slogan as well but we shouldn't we
should throw that slogan out
it's
the the idea is that we don't need to
teach students facts
we don't need to teach them dates and
facts and battles and what actually
happened we just need to teach them
broad themes you know we just need to
teach them how to think so they can form
their own conclusions and sure some
people might say the mayflower landed in
1620 but you know if i say it landed in
1854 well that's just that's just my
truth you know that's just i just
learned how to think no
no that's not how education works you
actually can't teach someone how to
think without also teaching them what to
think yes we want to develop our higher
thinking skills but you need to know
some basic facts bro you need to know
the 2 plus two equals four if you're
going to think about higher mathematics
and if you're going to be the energy
secretary of the united states you need
to know how many barrels of oil the
united states consumes per day and if
you want to think about american history
and you want to even craft an american
government you need to know basic facts
about america like what happened when
the pilgrims got here and what the early
relationship between the pilgrims and
the indians was and how the united
states was set you need to know these
basic things and unfortunately
what we have done because of airheaded
ideologues like the people on msnbc and
the gucci sweater guy and even now our
cabinet secretaries what we have done is
replaced hard facts and and true
education with airy wishy-washy socially
constructed always fluid ideology now
when you want to support america i would
strongly recommend you support american
ranchers which is why you got to check
out good ranchers did you know that the
product of usa tag has been stolen by
foreign countries a lot of times maybe
most of the time when you go to the
supermarket and you buy your meat and
you think you're buying american meat
you're not actually buying american meat
so why not just go to the best source
out there the good ranchers good
ranchers have gone around to great
american ranches found top quality meats
they have got
my favorite which are the burgers the
burgers are really good but they've got
fillets they've got all sorts of
different cuts of beef they've got
better than organic chicken head on over
right now to the good ranchers
do not allow labeling laws that favor
foreign countries deprive
american ranchers of your business and
deprive you of good american meat go to
goodranchers.com knowles right now get
10 free bistro fillets in addition you
will if you subscribe save 25 off of
each subscription box of mouth-watering
american meats for life the boxes will
show up right on schedule to your door
that is 10 free bistro fillets that's a
119 value free express shipping and 25
dollars off your monthly subscription
for life at goodranchers.com knowles
that is goodranchers.com knowles use
code knowles to check out 10 free beast
triplets
free express shipping 25 bucks off your
monthly subscription for life at
goodranchers.comknowles
speaking of not knowing what or how to
think
the the rot of the biden administration
competency goes all the way to the top
joe biden was making some remarks just
yesterday
and he was reading from a teleprompter
as he always does a lot of presidents do
and he
couldn't even differentiate between the
words on the prompter that he was
supposed to say
and the words he was not supposed to say
there's a lot of innovation
because of the actions we've taken
things have begun to change
and to quote in the past three weeks
end of quote end of qu he read end of
quote
we because and because of what we've
done
things have begun to change i'm ron
burgundy i'm this is the ron burgundy
presidency this is a man who
not only cannot speak extemporaneously
because he doesn't know what's going on
and he's obviously in decline
this is a man who can't even read the
teleprompter and it's not just flubbing
over one word or two words
this is a man who doesn't even know how
teleprompters work who doesn't even know
his speeches work end of quote i know it
seems like a minor flub but it's not
it's part of a much
larger
pattern
and we've all seen it and i think even
joe biden's partisans can't really deny
it even joe biden's physician can't deny
you know
the president just had a physical the
other day
and
very often when presidents have
physicals what happens is the doctor
afterwards says you know everything's
great everything's totally fine he's
doing great don't worry no problems here
joe biden's physician couldn't do that
couldn't do it in good conscience
couldn't do it with a straight face
because we all see the problems so joe
biden's physician concluded
you know there are some physical issues
he's clearing his throat a lot that
might be evidence of some other health
issues you know just the fact that he
can't seem to get through a sentence
without clearing his throat
the president's ambulatory gait the way
he walks is perceptively stiff stiffer
and less fluid than it was a year or so
ago so the guy is having trouble walking
it's not good this is in the president's
official physical
he has
the president has several reasonable
explanations for his his difficulty
walking in his orthopedic history but
again a detailed investigation was
appropriate and then here's the crucial
part
there was no mental test
no test of mental acuity that was
that was administered to the president
you'll remember when trump was president
people made fun of him because he took a
mental test his people were saying that
he was crazy and senile and he obviously
wasn't i mean no matter what you think
of trump you might hate the guy you
might think he's evil you might think
he's a huckster whatever but
you've got to admit he's sharp right the
the evidence that trump is sharp is his
sense of humor
right the the fact that he could be
asked by megyn kelly in a debate about
how he called women fat slobs ugly
animals pigs and he doesn't miss a beat
and he says no only rosie o'donnell
that's a that's a very funny line
okay that
that would take a professional showman a
professional comedian like trump is
to be able to do that you got to be
quick to tell a joke like that
okay and trump obviously was quick you
might hate his guts but still he was
quick and so and and he even made a joke
about the mental test and talked about
he was a genius and and
the like joe biden couldn't take the
test
he didn't take the test because
he couldn't take the test
which means my biggest takeaway from all
of that is not that by this is going to
collapse tomorrow my biggest take away
from all of that is that the democrats
don't have a 2024 plan
they don't is this guy really going to
run again maybe maybe they're going to
try to drag him over the finish line but
they're going to have to make up another
pandemic because
if this guy hits the campaign trail it's
going to be very bad so they're going to
have to find some excuse to lock him in
his room
or he steps down and then what and then
what
number two is even less popular than he
is biden's approval rating is 38.
kamalas is 28 27 or 28 lower than dick
cheney when he shot the guy in the face
what what makes you think that putting
kamala harris on the trail is going to
be any better kamala harris was asked
while she was giving remarks to explain
why the prices are going up she said
what they said what's your answer for
the rampant inflation here's her
searching for an answer
prices have gone up
and
families and individuals
are dealing with the realities of of the
that bread costs more the gas costs more
wow thank you professor harris that's
really astounding stuff i hold on can i
take notes can you go back to the uh uh
price has gone up uh-huh yeah we know
that that's the premise of the question
so why what's happening what are you
going to do about that um uh people
they pay more uh-huh yup i know that's
what inflation is so what are you going
to do about it um gas is
bread is high yup that's right the
democrats are not sending their best
this is the problem
with
selecting a vice president purely on the
basis of her genitals and race which is
the only reason this woman was selected
joe biden admitted that
long before he ever picked kamala harris
he said i'm going to pick a black woman
and then he backed himself into a corner
because in terms of the black women who
were prominent enough in public life to
be the vice president
there there weren't many options you had
karen bass who is an actual democrat
actually she's an actual democrat and an
actual communist like she has been a
member of communist organizations you
had susan rice who was the fall man for
benghazi you i guess you had stacey
abrams who's the the fake governor of
georgia she's the pretender governor of
georgia and you had kamala harris who
was the first person out of the democrat
race because no one likes her because
she's really not that good she's she's
good at backroom politics i'll just
leave it at that but
she's not good at front-facing politics
people don't like her it's why her
approval rating is in the doldrums and
now the democrats are paying for that
they are now paying
for
the this identity politics vice
presidency and the white house knows it
jen saki
who increasingly has the most difficult
job in the world jen saki was asked
about kamala harris's low approval
ratings and
rather than deny it rather than play it
down
she actually laughed about it
but her approval ratings are low i mean
is that do you think that's spreading to
the american people when they when they
answer some of these polls and and have
an opinion about her
look i think we've seen um it's not a
secret anita we've seen some drop in
approval ratings um you know across the
board i will say that um we also have to
be and we are very sober about the fact
that um there are some challenges real
challenges people are going through in
this country
uh uh madam press secretary uh the vice
president's approval ratings are below
dirt they are underground at this point
um what do you say about that
yeah they're pretty low huh
so
two two takeaways here
uh one one takeaway is that there's
there's no way to defend this there's
really no way to spin 27 approval rating
okay for your vice president who's doing
nothing the vice president should have a
higher approval rating than joe biden
who is taking all of the flack and yet
hers is still significantly lower so
there's no
there's no really good explanation for
that uh but the other thing
that i think you should take away here
is
biden and harris clearly despise one
another
right there is no joe kamala team here
they hate one another kamala harris
launched her presidential bid calling
joe biden a racist
joe biden didn't like that very much and
he chased her out of the race and kamala
harris was was the first person out
and then because he backed himself into
a corner he had to pick her but they
don't like each other the white house is
not going to save kamala harris they're
not going to boost her they keep giving
her the worst jobs right they say oh
kamala you're going to be in charge of
fixing immigration good luck
enjoy go enjoy el paso go have a good
time
send us some tamales and so it's she
they give her an impossible job she
takes a ton of flack
which means that the democrats do not
have
any particularly viable plan in 2024.
joe biden can barely walk and kamala
much much less run for president kamala
harris
is deeply deeply unlikable and they're
going to keep sniping at each other and
the whole and kamala's going to keep
calling joe a racist and joe is going to
keep laughing at kamala's bad approval
ratings
that's good news for us
the only good news for biden's kamala
harris is his insurance policy you don't
like me well look who's coming after me
this this is actually something trump
did with pence because as much as libs
pretended that donald trump is the
second coming of you know francisco
franco or something or mussolini
he wasn't he was he's actually kind of a
moderate guy on a lot of policies
and mike pence was the a little more of
the kind of religious right type of
conservative and so the insurance policy
was all right you get rid of trump
you're gonna have to deal with mike
pence much more of a religious right
type figure than donald trump ever was
so they they know that
and they also know that a lot of their
plans at the white house are falling
apart most notably
the vaccine mandate
which is why we're seeing the white
house getting increasingly desperate
and increasingly lawless you know the
biden administration pushes its employer
vaccine mandate
through osha the occupational safety and
health administration
this is almost certainly
unconstitutional
daily wire is leading the fight to sue
the biden administration the case goes
to the court of appeals
the court issues a stay it says don't
enforce the mandate the biden
administration says enforce the mandate
anyway then osha the administration
itself
the agency says
we are going to suspend our mandate
biden doesn't care
you know if you want to talk about your
health
if you want to feel better i would
strongly recommend you check out echelon
i want to stay fit i want to stay felt
and i don't have any time because i'm in
this studio 25 hours a day how do i do
it the answer is simple i'm not driving
to a gym that is simply not going to
happen i'm not going to go join the
football team that's not going to happen
echelon has made it possible echelon is
the affordable way to get the workout
equipment the workout community and an
instructor's motivation right in the
comfort of your own home echelon's
fitness app
provides you with thousands of live and
on-demand classes with great music with
echelon you can work out any time day or
night and crush your fitness goals
wherever you are echelon's full range of
affordable workout equipment including
stationary bikes smart rowers sleek
fitness screens and the auto folding
treadmill
are all connected to provide the echelon
experience
i love it i absolutely love my echelon
super it's the only thing that's going
to get me to work out one membership
covers a family of five for right now
podcast listeners
our listeners will get up to eight
hundred dollars off msrp to get this
exclusive podcast discount text knowles
know wles to eight one eight one 8181
text knowles k wles to 818181
to get up to 800 off msrp
text knowles 281 81 81 also the daily
wire shop is live and ready for all your
extremely important christmas needs you
know i know that you're you're very much
looking to buy this this black friday
and cyber monday you want to buy reasons
to vote for democrats a comprehensive
guide my number one bestselling blank
book and you're thinking maybe i'll buy
that on amazon maybe i'll buy it at
barnes and noble you definitely want to
buy speechless controlling words
controlling minds my number one national
best-selling a book with words that came
out this year and you were thinking
maybe i'll go to amazon maybe i'll go to
barnes and noble well you can go to any
of those places but where i would
recommend you go is the daily wire merch
shop that's right dailywire.com shop
check out all the brilliant collections
like the do not comply tees and let's go
brandon tailgate gear and a ton of my
stuff we've got great
cigar label t-shirts with my mug on it
and my my uh cigar motto which is the
body as a temple in the temple needs
incense we've got smokey mike and the
god king merch really top of the line
kind of stuff we've got the faucet
t-shirt it's a shake of arbor with
faushi's face on it anyone can shop at
the daily wire store but only dw members
will get special discounts up to 20 off
members also receive access to shop
exclusive items like signed copies of
candace owens's book blackout or
speechless or control over reason to
vote for democrats uh you can also get
the iconic leftist tears tumblr they are
selling fast go to dailywire.com
shop if you're not a member yet sign up
dailywire.com subscribe enter code dw35
you'll get 35 off your membership all
the perks you wouldn't get otherwise the
deal ends tomorrow on membership so make
sure you grab that discount while you
can
we'll be right back with a lot more
biden tells osha to tell employers with
a hundred or more employees to take the
fouchy algae
some of those companies notably the
daily wire sue joe biden over this the
court
tells
biden to stop telling osha to stop
telling the employers with a hundred or
more employees to take the fouchyache
biden tells the court to go pound sand
and biden tells osha to keep in making
the employers make the employees to take
the fauchiachi now osha
is telling the employers who were
telling the employees to get the
factuality that they are going to
suspend their mandate
until the issue is resolved in court are
you confused enough yet i certainly am
uh the reporters asked jen saki about
this yesterday here's what the white
house has to say osha suspended its
vaccine implementation
and enforcement because of a court order
given this update is the administration
still urging businesses to move forward
with
the president's vaccine and weekly
testing rule and are you still working
off of that january 4th compliance
deadline
we are let me be very clear our message
to businesses right now is to move
forward with measures that will make
their workplaces safer and protect them
their workforces from covid19 that was
our message after the first day issued
by the fifth circuit that remains our
message and nothing has changed i would
note that recent polling i think that
just came out yesterday showed that 60
of businesses are moving forward with
measures that keep their workplaces safe
they're essentially implementing
components or versions of these vaccine
requirements because they know it's in
the interests of their workforces to
protect their workforces to make sure
they can bring more people back to the
workforce and we certainly see that as a
positive sign
so we have been looking at this as a
battle between
the executive branch and the judicial
branch
right the executive branch says take the
fauchiachi the judicial branch says hold
up
but there's another player here in the
government as well that's the
administrative state the deep state the
executive agencies osha itself
and so now you've got the judiciary
saying hold up you've got osha saying
hold up and you've got joe biden saying
ignore both of those take the fauchiachi
anyway what this proves
and you know i hate to say i told you so
what this proves is that we were right
we were right when we said this is
unconstitutional this is bs biden knows
it's unconstitutional it's almost
certainly going to be struck down by the
courts and biden knows that and doesn't
care what he is hoping
is that enough employers force enough
employees to take the fauchiachi
before the court strikes it down that
it's a moot point
the court strikes down the biden order
okay whoopsie daisy anyway 99 of the
country's facts now too bad
even osha
because osha fears the court and the
people running osha fear the court they
say okay hold on we're gonna hold this
up
vine says yeah never mind
yeah whatever okay whatever osha says
whatever the course whatever just just
do it
by whatever means you need to
force your guys to take the voucher this
is lawless
and i never want to hear
from the libs again that we're
undermining democracy
and the rule of law and or principles
because of trump and the insurrection
and then no you are the ones who are now
openly advocating flouting the rule of
law flouting the courts flouting even
the administrative agency
and just bullying
americans millions and millions of
americans to take this experimental drug
to sort of fight off a virus that for
the vast majority of people does not
pose a particularly grave
threat
speaking of lawlessness
waukesha wisconsin you know there was
the attack oh we're not allowed to call
it an attack
there was the incident
at the christmas parade where a blm
supporter drove his suv down and killed
five people and injured many many more
people well now that number has been
updated it wasn't just five people it's
six people
a sixth person a child an eight-year-old
child
has died from the car attack in waukesha
wisconsin
now the number of people injured it's no
longer just 20 people or 40 people it's
now up to 61 people injured
cbs 8 is reporting that the
eight-year-old boy died and his
12-year-old brother was also hit
during the massacre
the
you're not going to hear a lot of this
from the establishment media but the guy
who drove the car was
according to a social media reportedly a
blm supporter a big critic of of
trump and the republicans and
conservatives he espoused black
nationalist rhetoric this came right
after the kyle rittenhouse verdict which
was exploited by the media and tried to
turn into a blm cause celeb and
and he was also this driver of the car
out on bail
he had been he had actually just been uh
leaving another domestic incident but he
had been arrested for domestic abuse he
hit he hit a woman the mother of his
children he hit her with a car same
corey used to hit kill all these other
people and he was released on bail and
the bail was a thousand bucks and before
that just last year he was arrest
arrested again for all these problems he
was released on 500 bail this guy is a
degenerate dirty rotten criminal who
should have been locked up at least at
least locked up
for a very long time if not the rest of
his life
and because of the compassionate
liberals and criminal justice reform
which
these days even many republicans are
embracing because of that
61 people were injured and six people
were killed including an eight-year-old
boy and who knows more people might die
there's still people in critical
condition
because of that compassion and now you
want to hear the cherry on top of the
sunday
he's got he's got the opportunity for
bail again
now the bail is very high this time
they've set the bail at five million
dollars
why are they giving him that opportunity
at all
he is a repeat
violent career criminal who has killed
who has injured many many people and
killed
multiple people why does he have the
opportunity for bail
i agree he should have a trial though it
though in a in a simple efficient just
world that isn't fallen
this would be over already
but yes he of course he's entitled to a
trial
but he's not entitled to go out there's
if the guy goes he's already
skipped his bail before he's already
he's already committed crimes while out
on bail
so just you can't give him that
opportunity again
and in our crazy
compassionate world
he is being given that opportunity there
was also a media narrative there's so
many lies in the media around this this
attack one of them was that the reason
he drove his suv into the crowd into the
christmas parade and killed a bunch of
grannies the dancing grannies was one of
the names of one of the groups and
killed children is because he was being
chased by the police that was that was
the narrative that was starting to form
and it of course it is because nothing
can be this criminal's fault everything
has to be the fault of the police
why did you commit the crime the police
made me do it the law made me do it the
society made me do it it can never be
the fault of the criminal
and especially when you add the racial
dimension here that the left pushes it's
all the white guy has to always be at
fault even if the cop is black actually
as is the case in
this part of wisconsin it's still it's
the white guy and the poor black guy is
always the victim
and the you see it in the narrative
around thanksgiving the settlers the
pilgrims they're always the bad guy the
indians are always the victim there's no
ambiguity here
it always breaks to end even if the
reality doesn't match that narrative the
the reality must be made to conform
with that narrative so uh the cop here
in waukesha came out milwaukee police
came out
and said that that media narrative just
is not true we have information that the
suspect prior to the incident was
involved in domestic disturbance
which was just minutes prior
and the suspect left that scene just
prior to our arrival
to that domestic disturbance
when
the suspect was driving through into the
crowd
one officer did discharge his fire arm
and fired shots at the suspect to stop
the threat
but due to the amount of people had to
stop
and
stop and fire noah did not buy any other
additional shots there's no evidence
that this is a terrorist incident
okay now
this last part is a little
questionable to me but to the first part
he's saying
the
the guy was involved in a domestic
disturbance he was beating his baby mama
as he frequently did and so the cops
went to that scene but he had already
left that scene so it's not like he was
there and the cops got there and then he
fled and ran away and then the cops just
chased him he had already left by the
time the cops got there
he was already driving his car into the
people
by the time the cops shot at him to stop
him from doing that and then the cops
had to stop shooting because there were
so many people around because it was a
christmas parade
and yet
the cop says this is not a terrorist
incident
well what does that mean does it mean
this this is not al qaeda yeah i don't
think it's al-qaeda
does this mean
this was not isis yeah i don't think it
was isis
but
are we certain
that this guy did not have any political
motive what is what is terrorism
terrorism in its most simple form
is the targeting of civilians
to achieve a political end
the people here were killed were
civilians
the guy who drove the car
had clearly or reportedly clearly
articulated political views about blm
black about black black nationalism
about trump and conservatives and
written house and all these people
the written house verdict came out just
days before this incident
i'm not saying
that we know for certain that it was
politically motivated it might have just
been the guy's a nut and he's a violent
criminal and he's a dirty rotten
degenerate and he beats his baby mom and
runs her over with a car and he just
felt like killing some people that night
it might have been that
but are we we're certain
this had no political motive i don't
think so
and compare it of course compared of
course to kyle rittenhouse
kyle rittenhouse
goes out
defends a town that he works in whereas
part of his family lives
and
he is instantly smeared white
supremacist this is terrorism we know
his motives without any evidence
whatsoever
now we actually do have evidence of a
political motive here
we there is no claim possible that this
guy was acting in self-defense like kyle
rittenhouse who was just proven to have
acted in self-defense
and yet we're told no political motive
whatsoever i don't buy that meanwhile
meanwhile
remember charlottesville you remember
the unite the right rally some years ago
plaintiffs in that rally were just
awarded 25 million dollars
25 million dollars in damages over the
2017 unite the right rally in
charlottesville the way that they were
and they were awarded this from people
like richard spencer and other white
identitarians
the lawyers for the plaintiffs used 150
year old law that was passed after the
civil war
that's known as the ku klux klan act
that contains this provision that's very
rarely used that allows private citizens
to sue other citizens for civil rights
violations
the left is very happy about this which
is funny because
the left is very upset about the
abortion law in texas
that allows private citizens to sue
other private citizens for civil rights
violations
right that's the mechanism that the
pro-life law in texas works by and the
left is furious about that and says it's
unconstitutional evil and terrible but
they're using a similar law here to sue
white identitarian people
because of physical or emotional harm
not caused by these people but caused by
people who were leading the march that
which there was violence
james fields is the uh
guy who drove his car into a crowd and
killed heather heyer at the unite the
right rally
uh
james fields is serving life in prison
he's that guy's not getting out of
prison so he's already
faced his punishment or is facing his
punishment
three other unite the right protesters
were accused and and
more than protesters here they were
accused of surrounding and beating
a black counter-protester deandre harris
in a video that went viral now
harris himself was the guy who was the
victim in the meeting was also charged
with unlawful wounding following an
assault on
an alleged white identitarian during
that protest uh corey long
who was uh one of the counter protesters
i was shown wielding an improvised
flamethrower against a white
identitarian at the protest he was also
arrested
okay it's very very complicated but now
they've 25 million dollars in damages
from the white identitarians
what happened in waukesha
was by every single measure
much much worse
than what happened in charlottesville
but waukesha will be shrugged off the
political dimensions if there is one
will be completely denied and downplayed
the
deaths will be downplayed it will just
be another sad thing never mind moving
on charlottesville will be held up as
the worst attack ever in american
history
even though the guy who committed the
crime that day is serving life in prison
he completely got his just desserts but
that will be held up constantly as
justice was not done this is the worst
thing that's ever happened but if you
just look at the death count if you look
at the mayhem if you look it's not even
comparable but this is because
in the united states
the left gets away with violence
and the right when it commits violence
obviously doesn't get away with it and
when the right even doesn't commit
violence or acts in self-defense or just
sort of speaks they
are held to a completely different
standard
kyle rittenhouse just came out he did an
interview with tucker
and
kyle rittenhouse was asked about his
political views and he shocked a lot of
people and a lot of his supporters when
he said that he supports
black lives matter
this case has nothing to do with race um
it never had anything to do with race it
had to do with the right to self-defense
right
i'm not a racist person i support the
blm movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
and it's just amazing to see
how
how much a prosecutor can take advantage
of somebody it's not it's never like
that i love blm i'm a great guy so
a blm responded and they don't
apparently they're not very welcoming of
kyle rittenhouse they say alexa play i
don't f with you and then they you know
had a bunch of tweets about how terrible
the written house verdict was and how
it's emblematic of white supremacy
well the right here
is giving written house a lot of advice
and a lot of conservatives are saying
kyle you're you're so mistaken and naive
they're not going to accept you at blm
and blm's a radical marxist organization
you shouldn't allow yourself with blm
i i don't really believe that i don't
think that
i i believe those criticisms but i don't
believe that kyle rittenhouse actually
supports blm he obviously does not
i think kyle rittenhouse is saying this
because he's about to sue a bunch of
media organizations for for defamation
and i think this helps his case and
because the media organization's acted
so recklessly and irresponsibly he's
trying to make this point very clear but
he's probably just doing it for the the
libel suits here i can't imagine that a
kid with this kind of uh this this
articulate who's just been through all
of this could say in seriousness in
uh he supports
blm i just i just spit in 2021 i just
don't buy it after blm torched the
country for six months i don't think so
speaking of criminals
the colorado
sex offender management board just voted
last friday
to get rid of the term
sex offender
meaning
presumably that the colorado sex
offender management board will now just
be called the colorado management board
you know it sounds
much more boring if
it's just the management board you know
it's just upper management
they voted to change the term to quote
adults who commit sexual offenses
in its standards guidelines for
assessment evaluation treatment and
behavioral monitoring of adult sex
offenders which i guess now has to be
adults who commit sexual offenses
here's their explanation
the board writes quote the language
change applies only to s-o-m-b standards
the term sex offender will continue to
be used in colorado statute and the
criminal justice system including courts
law enforcement and the colorado sex
offender registry the name somd itself
will also remain unchanged okay so
they're still going to call it the sex
offender management board
but they're not going to use that term
anymore other than
in the law and in the name of their
organization
why are they doing it well kimberly
klein a licensed counselor and the
chairman of the board
says quote i think the biggest thing is
research really shows us that assigning
a label has the potential for negative
effects in rehabilitation
i think that's that's probably true
to some degree i think it's probably
true if you think of yourself if you
ground your identity
in being a sex offender then it's
probably going to be harder to overcome
that identity
just like if you ground your identity in
being a drug addict it's going to be
harder to overcome that identity
just like if you ground your identity in
being a transgender cis
whatever you know i don't know all of
these various sexual things then it's
it's hard for you to think outside of
that box it's hard you just you put
yourself in a box and you can't get
outside of it which is why
nations that are christian
nations that find their identity in god
who is
transcendent being himself right when
moses asks god who shall i tell them you
are and god says i am that i am i am i
am being
if you find your identity in the i am
then that's going to open up a lot of
opportunity to you and free you and if
you don't do that if you turn away from
god you're you're going to be left with
this pitiful question who am i this is
why teenagers in particular try on all
sorts of silly identities and then they
get locked in those identities for a
while and then they're ultimately
unsatisfying so they discord them so i
actually grant the point that this that
the sex offender board is is making
and and it comes it actually we were
talking about this yesterday it actually
comes from a place of sort of christian
charity
right it comes from this concern for
all sorts of victims even people who are
victims of vice and sin who are
committing crimes themselves even they
are sort of victims of this
but it does so to the point of absurdity
right it tries to out-christian the
christians it tries to
turn everyone into a victim and the
perpetrators are the greatest victims of
all according to this ideology
it tries to
help people by denying reality
but denying reality does not help
anybody
it doesn't
you need to grapple with the fact
that if you're a sex offender you have
committed sexual offenses you've got to
grapple with that
you need a sense of sin
you can only get back into communion
with god after you've gone through
confession after you've dealt with that
sin and that crime yourself you can only
come back having paid your debt to
society after you
pay that debt after you go through the
criminal justice system and if we try to
skip that part
if we just let violent criminals off the
hook and they pay a 500 bail and they're
out
you're you're not going to have that
flourishing wonderful safe society
you're going to get more mayhem and more
death and destruction and more crime
speaking of sex offenders
i've got to cover this story this is
very very important
the new york times has a new report out
on how epstein geoffrey epstein spent
his final days in prison so this after a
long time
the new york times
uh has new documents from the fbi fbi
often will leak to the new york times
and here it's unclear if the documents
were already available but the new york
times is reporting on them so how did
jeffrey epstein end his final days in
prison i assume and i didn't really need
a new york times report for this that it
was pleading with hillary clinton for
his life
as he was please hillary please don't do
it put it down please hillary put the
noose and the gun down please but
uh no
no it turned out that he was saying he
had no plans of suicide and he was
living a wonderful life and who knows
he's a pathological liar and a
narcissist but
very few people believe that jeffrey
epstein killed himself very few people
have faith in our institutions anymore
as they crumble we can't even agree on
basic aspects of american history on
american public life even to like our
own country uh
we're gonna have to deal with that
problem before we deal with the
uh problem the political issues that
come downstream of that and one way to
start dealing with that problem is to
have a good thanksgiving give thanks to
god for the blessings love your country
uh give a maybe pour one out for the
pilgrims you know the guys who gave you
this country and enjoy your families i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
i will see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
john bickley here daley wire editor in
chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the galain maxwell
trial is set to begin the us suffers a
record number of overdose deaths and
protests break out in europe over covet
restrictions
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire
bye